nos dicen que el radio de una esfera
puede ser medido usando la fórmula era
igual a la raíz cúbica de 3 b entre 4 pi
donde b es el volumen esto es
interesante usualmente te dan el volumen
como función del radio y aquí es al
revés no están dando el radio como
función del volumen si el radio de la
esfera es 6 pulgadas entonces no están
dando el radio de 6 pulgadas no están
dando esto de aquí el radio si el radio
de 6 pulgadas
cuál es su volumen tenemos entonces 6
pulgadas todo está en pulgadas esto es
igual a la raíz cúbica la raíz cúbica de
3 b tenemos que despejar b sobre 4 pi
como primer paso nos deshacemos de la
raíz cúbica elevando al cubo ambos lados
entonces tenemos del lado izquierdo 6
elevado al cubo y del lado derecho
tenemos la raíz cúbica de 3 b sobre 4 p
elevado al cubo ahora el lado izquierdo
de esta igualdad es 6 al cubo eso es 6
por 6 36
6 680 36 216 6 al cubo es igual a 216
216 si el radio está en pulgadas al
elevado al cubo esto es pulgadas cúbicas
y esto es igual del lado derecho que
tenemos tenemos que la raíz cúbica de
324 pi estamos elevando al cubo aquí
tenemos el exponente a la un tercio
multiplicado por tres se hace un
exponente uno por lo cual nos queda tres
b entre cuatro pi bien para despejar b
de esta ecuación la multiplicamos por el
recíproco de su coeficiente el recíproco
de tres entre cuatro pies cuatro pi
sobre tres multiplicamos ambos lados
déjame asegurarme que lo puedas ver bien
multiplicamos ambos lados por cuatro p
sobre tres la razón por la cual estamos
multiplicando por cuatro pie entre tres
es que se elimine con tres entre cuatro
pi así es que aquí cuatro pie el
numerador con cuatro pie el denominador
se simplifica se eliminan tres el
numerador contra ese denominador
simplificar y nos resulta entonces que b
es igual a 4 p tercios por 216 esto lo
puede escribir de la siguiente manera
esto lo puede escribir como 216 que
multiplica 216 que multiplica que
ponerlo con el mismo color 206 que
multiplica a 4 p sobre 3 ahora 216 2 más
1 369 este la manera de ver si es
múltiplo de tres al sumar los dígitos
nos da un múltiplo de 3 así es que si es
divisible entre 3 vamos a simplificar
216 entre 3 vamos de la división 216
entre 3 21 entre 3 a 7 7 por 3 21
bajamos el 6
entonces nos queda 6 entre 3 es 22 por
36 menos 6 es igual a 0 72 216 entre 3
es igual a 72 72 por 4 pi es igual al
volumen y esto está en pulgadas cúbicas
así que 4 por 72 4 por 70 es 280 4 por 2
es 8 por lo que 4 por 72 es 288 y esto
está en pulgadas cúbicas y ese es
nuestro volumen y así hemos terminado